pass deflected by butler tries to save
it
and it finds its way to robinson down to
butler and butler throws it down it's
back to a one-point game
we see what mark talked about that
length and the hustle
and instead of
butler to the rim banks at home we're
tied again
dragach now five to shoot lost it
momentarily pulls back dragach a
three-pointer
bang gorham druggish from downtown
and the heat lead by five has made big
plays
all bubble long put this team on his
back when it mattered most
not afraid of the moment beautiful
offense
agoran dragon smart to inbound
ball pumped away by butler butler with
the steal
butler back to crowder banks at home
jimmy butler with another huge defensive
play
great zone defense
walker brown brown tries a three that's
good
jalen brown from way downtown and it's
back to four
dragons tries again dragons pulls back
shot is up
that's good gorham dragon they've
switched to pick and roll and dragach
has come up
big smart tied up back out
jalen brown tries again puts it in
another three for jalen brown
celtics won't go away it's a three-point
game
smart to inbound they lob it up to brown
ball broken up picked up by crowder
crowder throws it
out of bio